To see the Ecommerce data, go to
Conversions > Ecommerce > Overview.
So far, nobody's actually bought
anything in my app so I have no revenue.
Let's look at shopping behavior.
Shopping Analysis > Shopping Behavior,
okay, that looks a bit more colorful.
I had some sessions where some users,
who are actually all me at this stage,
viewed some products.
Then there was another session where
a user added the product to the cart.
But I still haven't implemented
the checkout code, so
no checkouts, which is confirmed if
I look at the Checkout Behavior page.
Nobody started checkout.
Let's look at Product Performance.
I see the product dinner listed, but
it hasn't brought any money in yet.
This report includes products that
got as far as at least being added to
the cart.
If I drill down into the product, I see
a list of the SKUs, which is the same as
product IDs for the products that were
involved in the shopping process.
If I set the Secondary dimension
to Ecommerce > Product Variant,
I can see the names of the dinners
as well as the dinner ID.
And feel free to explore what other
Secondary dimensions you can view.